So, if he doesn't want to talk, what you
going to do?
>> Oh, you don't want to talk about
>> If you don't want to If you don't want
to talk about the Islamic dilemma, if
you don't want to let me pick a topic
like you promised, then you have no
honor and we're not going to talk. It's
simple. I'm not going to I'm not going
to debate about Okay, cool. So, you
chose to talk. All right. Whatever helps
you sleep.
>> Whatever helps you sleep. I don't want
to talk to you, bro.
>> I don't want to talk to you. You got it.
>> Cuz you're saying a lot like anything in
trying to run. You hear that? Don't talk
like anything.
>> Don't listen to trying to run. You hear
that? Don't talk.
I'm a scholar from student.
>> How you guys doing?
>> How you doing?
>> Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you. Hey,
>> so I ain't saying I know everything, but
you know,
>> talk about some topics that are
important. I don't know how you want to
set this up. You want to do like um I
say one topic, you say one topic. One of
time no time.
>> Yeah. No time. Just I I like a good
flowing conversation. I like a open
dialogue. So um if if you want to talk
about something, you want to pick
something you want to talk about, I'm
down to talk about that.
>> She said you guys were handing out
pamphlets. Is that a different group or
or is it just too windy today? I know
you can't
>> I think Jesus
makes sense
>> where he say he's not God
that
>> okay
>> it would have made sense it would have
made sense yesterday for like taxes or
the hour
>> about Thursday the 16th
>> able to actually debunk that
>> okay
>> I think Jesus says he doesn't know the
hour
>> you said that they had not just him he
says everyone else you know the angels
the father. What would what would be
your explanation to that?
>> Yeah, sure. Yeah. So, when it comes to
what Jesus is talking about there, you
got to look at uh um how the word no is
being used in the context. So,
>> the word you want to
>> are you guys going to have a separate
conversation?
>> Okay.
>> I mean, are you wanting to dialogue with
me because it sounded like you wanted
>> No, no, it's fine. I can talk to or you
can join as well. No problem.
>> Yeah. So, I I don't know what but we we
can talk. Um, if anybody wants to chime
in or anything at any time, I'm I'm
cool. You know, it's not like formal or
anything like that. So, um, but yeah, so
it's it's uh looking at how the word no
is used there in the Greek. And so, um,
the word is oien, which can also mean to
tell something or to declare something.
And so when you look at it, Jesus is not
saying that it's like he's talking about
cognitive knowledge, but it's not for
any man, any angel or even for the son
to declare, but that's a role for the
father to do only. And so um um you can
see this like for example, Paul uses the
same word in 1 Corinthians chapter 2. He
says to the Corinthians, he says, "When
I came to you, I decided to know nothing
among you except Jesus. I'm used the
same word Jesus uses." And so obviously
that doesn't mean that Paul didn't know
anything. It just means that he didn't
come to make anything else known or
declare anything except the crucifixion
of Jesus. So in the same way Jesus is
saying it's not for anyone to declare
the hour that's for the father to do the
>> make sense.
>> So your your explanation to that is that
verse or that word it means to declare.
>> Yeah.
>> Saying no one's going to declare the
hour not the angels
>> not the son only the father. Correct.
>> Yes sir. Yes sir.
>> Okay. Why do why do uh um Bible
translators translate it to declare?
>> Because like all all of them translated
to knowledge.
>> Good question. Cuz because it is it's
the the word translates to know, but the
meaning is based on the context. So like
so for example, you have in the Old
Testament in the Hebrew it says in
Genesis, I think it's Genesis either
five or one of those where it says Adam
knew his wife and she bore him a son. So
obviously he already knew her before
that. So it's it's but it's talking
about sexual intercourse. But the word
translates to no or to new. So
>> yes, but if a word can mean multiple
things though, they would translate it
to declare.
>> No, because why? Okay. So then why don't
they translate to the word no there to
sexual intercourse
>> because that still fits in the context.
He knew.
>> That's my point. That's my point. So
>> No, no, but they they know they don't
need to translate to another word like
declare or something because it fits in
the context.
>> I agree. That's that's my point. So I'm
saying so when when Adam knew his wife
>> Yeah.
>> It's not a coming to know her
cognitively cuz he already knew her.
Right.
>> Okay. Now let me ask you a question.
>> Sure.
>> So that's that's the first point that
that um the the the translators don't
translate it to that. But the more
important point is does the context
allow for it to mean declared?
>> Absolutely.
>> Let's go read the context. Let's read it
out. Does Jesus give parables after he
talks about this? Sure does.
>> Okay. What does he give parables about?
Does he gives parables about cognitive
knowledge or does he give parable about
declaring?
>> Well, he gives a he gives a parable
about a master leaving and how the
followers
>> don't know when he will return. So,
notice he emphasizes their cognitive
knowledge, not his own.
>> Oh, interesting. Okay. So, Jesus says,
"No one knows the hour, not the angels
in the heaven, nor the son, only the
father."
>> And then right after he says just like a
master who leaves and he and the servant
doesn't know when he's going to come. So
he gives examples of cognitive
knowledge. Is the master declaring when
he's going to come or not? Or is he
talking about cognitive knowledge?
>> Yeah. So the so the master doesn't
declare when he comes. The students
don't know or his his servants don't
know.
>> But is he giving an example of declaring
or is he giving example?
>> Well in in this in this parable he gives
an example of cognitive knowledge for
the servants not himself. So if the just
really quick so for example if the
master is leaving
>> right he's going on a job. Does the
master know when he's going to return?
No,
>> he doesn't.
>> The master doesn't know when he's going
to come to his own house.
>> Master doesn't. The the servant.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So, the master knows,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, in this parable, who would the
master be?
>> Um,
>> who's going away
>> and then coming back? Who who would who
would the master be?
>> I would say that that it's not talking
about who the master is. It's talking
about knowledge.
>> No, I I know what you mean. saying it's
like no one knows and it's like the
master who goes and then servant doesn't
know he's going to
>> but but but when he when he when when he
makes a
>> parable doesn't allow for it to mean
>> oh it does let me show you why
>> Jesus makes it very clear it's about
cognitive
>> okay but okay you got to work with
things okay so when Jesus makes parables
parables are to communicate the truth of
what he's saying right so when he makes
parables there's characters that you
plug in for reality so the master for
example in the parable who would who's
the master in the parable
>> according to Jesus he's making this
comparison
This is a very long explanation.
>> Well, it's not it's not that long. We're
getting
>> is that you're saying that the father
doesn't want to declare the hour, right,
>> brother? We got to we got we got to
answer this first before we move on.
>> The father doesn't want to declare the
hour.
>> We got we got to answer this before we
move on. You
>> ask the question or not?
>> Yes. After after this
>> hour or not? That's that's your stance.
>> After this, my father's the only one who
declares the hour. Yes or no?
>> My brother, if you're if you're going to
do this and interrupt, I rather just
talk to him right now because we're
having a a bill.
>> You're avoiding this question.
>> I I'll answer you right after.
>> According to your interpretation, no
need to declare. So, according to verse,
only the father can declare the hour,
right?
>> I I'll answer that next.
>> Yes or no?
>> I'll answer that next.
>> I'll answer your question, then you'll
answer his question.
>> Yeah. Well, after we finish what we're
talking about, cuz I have no problem
dealing with that conversation. You
know, we got to we got to build
together.
>> Why don't we read the context so we
know, right? Okay.
>> Oh, I I don't want I don't want to
interrupt the discussion. I just wanted
to because I don't know your
perspective. Do you believe Jesus said
that or
>> do you believe Jesus said those words or
I I'm just wondering
>> like some some Muslims believe Jesus
said some of these things. Some Muslims
don't believe he said these things. you
actually because I know he believes in
it.
>> Okay. So you you don't believe that?
>> No, it doesn't matter. Just like he can
bring a verse in the Quran and say why
does the Quran say this? Even though he
doesn't believe in the Quran.
>> But anyways, let's read this. So right
of that day and hour, no one knows, not
even the angels of heaven, but my father
only. But as the days of Noah were, so
also will be will the coming of the son
of man be. For as in the days before the
flood, they were eating and drinking,
burying and giving in marriage until the
day that Noah entered the ark and did
not know until the flood came and took
them all away. So also will be the
coming of the son of man. And I'm not
going to read everything else and give
another you need to read it. Please I
can read it if you want to be super
hungry.
>> Then two men, he also gives example,
then two men will be in the field. One
will be taken and the other left. Two
women will be grinding out the mail. One
will be taken and the other left. Watch
therefore, for you do not know what what
hour your Lord is coming. But know this,
that if the master of the house had
known what hour the thief would come, he
would have watched and not allowed his
house to be broken into. Therefore, you
also be ready, for the son of man is
coming at an hour you do not expect.
>> All right? So, notice how he's saying
you don't know. You need to be ready.
Right? He's emphasizing their cognitive
knowledge. Now, if you go cuz that was
Matthew 24, right? Yes.
>> So go to go to Mark 13 really quick cuz
he gives
>> he just gives one instead of three,
>> right? So it's the same it's the same
exact
>> I know. Well, this one is different.
>> And this and this why this one is going
to be important.
>> Mark Mark 13. If you go to read after
32,
>> but like
take watch and pray for you do not know
what the title is. It's like a man going
to a fruitful tree and left his house
and gave authority to his servants and
to each independent the doorkeeper to
watch. Watch therefore not know when the
master of the house is coming in the
evening at midnight at the crowd in the
grocery store or in the morning.
>> Uh le coming suddenly he finds you
sleeping and what I say to you I say to
all watch.
>> Right? So now according to this in this
parable the master going away and then
he leaves his servants in charge. Right?
In the parable, who is the master that's
going away?
>> Jesus is not pointing to who the master
is.
>> Yes, he is. Because he says this is just
like this.
>> Can I explain?
>> So, he gave three examples, right? You
kind of went over the Noah one and you
went to you went to Mark cuz you didn't
want to talk about Noah and son of
>> No, that was that's not relevant to my
point.
>> He gave four total No, it's very
important cuz he gave four four total
parables
>> and all of them have one thing in
common. What is that one thing in
common? What about a master
>> that they don't know? I can just finish.
>> You asked me a question.
>> Oh, that's rhetorical. Okay. If it's not
about them not knowing or sorry it's not
about who the master is the thing about
the flood of know is not there's no
master. So you can't even say it's he's
trying to talk about who the master is.
It's not about this it's not about that.
It's at doubt he is talking about
cognitive knowledge.
>> Whose cognitive knowledge
>> the cognitive knowledge of who knows the
hour.
>> But who who does who does he say who is
who is he comparing the cognitive
knowledge of not knowing? He gives four
examples
>> and and he continues to go and say you
just like this you don't know
>> for the master
>> no no for all of them for the Noah one
he says just like how they didn't know
when the flood is coming you don't know
when the coming of the son of man is
just like when two men didn't know when
the thief is coming you don't know when
the son of man comes
>> and then he says just like no one knows
the father except the hour just like no
one knows the hour except the father
don't know that
>> so hold on a second though because this
is this is why you keep avoiding
answering this question when Jesus gives
the parable of the master going away.
What is he comparing that parable to?
The master going away.
>> He's comparing it to cognitive
knowledge.
>> That's not what I'm asking. There's like
I said,
>> I'm ask Hold on, please. I'm I'm going
to ask it one last time.
>> You're trying to dodge the
>> No. No. You're trying to dodge. I I we
we did Did we not just go through the
Did we not just go through every every
uh parable?
>> No.
>> So, we did we did I didn't just talk
about the Noah one. I didn't just talk
about the twoman one. I didn't just talk
about the thief one.
>> Yeah. But what happened?
>> Okay. Okay. So, the only one you didn't
want to cuz you cuz you don't cuz you
don't want to deal with the last parable
cuz you know cuz you you Okay. So, if
they're all the same, then stop playing
games and answer the question. I did.
Okay. So, the master who's going away,
what does Jesus make this parable and
compare it to?
>> He's comparing it to the cognitive
knowledge that the father has that no
one.
>> What's the situation like? What's the
situation being compared to
>> about a flood?
Is he am I is my question hard? All
right. I'm going to ask it one last
time. Sir,
>> what is the situation?
>> Yeah. Exactly. When the situation and he
says it's just like
>> a master who goes away on a far journey
and leaves his servants in charge.
>> What is that situation being likened to?
In reality,
>> that situation is being likened to the
cognitive knowledge that the father has,
neither the son nor the angel of the
heaven.
>> Who's the one going away?
>> He is not trying to say.
>> Notice how you're not answering. Who's
not? Who's the one going away
think the passage is only about
knowledge? There's nothing else.
>> Of course.
>> So who's going away, bro?
>> Out of all four examples, who's going
away?
>> Hold on. Let me let me about let me let
me let me ask you something. You is one
of them about brother. Hold on. I'm
sorry. Cuz I cuz I've been asking you
the same question for the past seven
minutes and No, you didn't. Again, I
asked who the master is. You said it's
not about that. That's not an answer. I
asked, "Okay, what's the situation being
likened to?" Oh, well, it's talking
about the cognitive. You're not
answering the question. So, no, no, I'll
make it simple. Answer your question.
Okay. Okay. So, who seems like you're
not understand? I
>> I'll ask it again. So, if you're going
to answer it simply
>> when he says it's just like, what's just
like a master going away and leaving his
servants behind? What is he likening
this situation?
>> I'll explain. Okay. Just give me one
minute so I can explain it. You don't
need a minute to explain this
>> because you are trying to say something
that I don't believe in.
>> I don't care what you believe. I care
about the text.
>> No, I'm saying what the text is trying
to say as well.
>> No, don't don't tell me what you think
the text is trying to say.
>> No, I'm telling you what it's simple.
You know what? How about this? Let me
let me try something else. Hey, David,
when when Jesus says this situation is
like a master going away, what is Jesus
comparing this parable to in reality? In
reality,
>> sounds like he's going away, leaving his
servants in charge. And then you'll have
the coming of the son of man when he
returns. That's what it sounds like.
>> So you see how So do you So do you see
how he was able to answer that? Wait,
>> you you take all that into account.
>> Yes. Wait. So hold on. So did you did
you do you agree with me? He's he's
Jesus is my brother. Do you do you agree
with him? I'll expand.
>> Oh, so that's not the situation he's
comparing to.
>> But if you're going to be this
dishonest, this I'm going to move on to
the next person.
>> You're being dishonest cuz you're not
trying to have my response. Okay. Go
ahead.
>> Okay. Listen. So you are trying to focus
on one of four parables because you know
that is the only one that you can
possibly make the master be Jesus and
you're trying to say that Jesus is
>> prove that it's not
>> I can just
finish
>> right you know I want to cut you off and
you
>> cut me off this whole time.
>> No you've been cut off
>> I really I've tried not to and if I did
I'm sorry.
>> Okay.
>> So anyways so you are trying to focus on
that example because you're trying to
make Jesus the master in that example.
So you're trying to make him be the one
that knows. What I'm saying is that
Avery, I do not believe that Jesus is
giving that example for us to see who
the master is or not. The reason why is
because when we look at all of it in
context and the four parables that he
gives, all of them have something
connected. It's not all of them have a
master. The flood one doesn't have a
master. He couldn't answer that. It's
all of them have talking about cognitive
knowledge. So you are trying to get me
to say something but I don't. You are
making the text say something that
doesn't say. Jesus is purely saying that
the master is going the servants do not
know. So it's about that is why I can
pull up 17 Bible translations that right
now and they all translate it to know.
That is why your early uh church fathers
like um uh Irenaeus and all these people
they say Jesus the son does not know.
Josephus they all say that and I can
pull up the quotes right now. So now let
me ask you something. Why does he give
four examples about cognitive knowledge
and he gives zero examples about
declare? Why is it that he doesn't do
that? Go ahead.
>> Okay. So, I let you speak.
>> Yes, I'll let you.
>> All right. Now, this is what I want you
cuz I don't want us to turn into
monologues.
>> I hope you can
>> I hope that you can
No, you No, you didn't. The only thing
that you did was dismiss what I asked
you. You said, see, what you're trying
to do is this and then you dodged it.
>> So, I'm going to ask you again. And
hopefully you can answer it this time.
Matter of fact, let me steal man your
position. So, I'm going to show you.
Please note now you're interrupting me.
>> So I'm going to steal man your position.
I'm going to show you that I understand
exactly what you're saying. And then
what I want you to do is engage with
what I'm saying. Fair enough.
>> Okay. So what you're saying is well
according to all the parables Jesus is
talking about the cognitive knowledge.
So nothing is about declare. So you're
making this up. But though and you're
trying to hold on to this master parable
out of the other three. you going to you
want to talk about this master parable
because it's the only one that you can
possibly show that Jesus knows
please please please thank you I
appreciate it I appreciate that the
irony of you saying that I'm not looking
at it in context issue
>> no it's all good it's all good so when
we already checked off and looked at the
other parables that Jesus mentioned
which is why I said there's one more
that you missed go to Mark 13 where he
gives this parable and you don't want to
deal with it so when I ask you this when
I m Stop. When I ask you the question
about this parable, you're the only one
out of this circle that doesn't want to
talk about it because you know it points
to Jesus knowing his own return. Now,
let me break this down to you. Jesus
says this is like this is similar to a
master. So his coming, him leaving and
then returning, the son of man's coming
is similar to a master who leaves his
house on a far journey and gives
authority to his servants to be in
charge and to work until he gets back.
So you don't know when when the master's
uh getting back. The servants don't know
when the master's coming back, but you
said that the master knows when he's
coming back. And so when you admitted
that, you immediately saw your mistake.
Because when you admit that the master
knows when he's coming back and Jesus
likens himself to the master who leaves
and is coming back, that means that
Jesus knows his own return, but it's the
servants who don't. It's the apostles
who don't. So I'm going to ask you
again, who is the master in the parable
that Jesus is comparing himself to?
>> Okay, now it's my turn, right?
>> Yeah, please answer directly.
>> So the master in that example, Jesus is
not talking.
>> Another non-answer. Can I You didn't
even
>> Don't tell me what he's not talking
about. Answer. I'm waiting for the
answer.
>> Look at the irony.
>> Yeah. Look at the irony. I'm waiting on
the answer. Let me talk. Let me talk
now.
>> I hope you answer.
>> You can only make it that Jesus is
trying to say he is the master. When you
take the one paragraph,
>> I just want I just want to know the
answer.
>> Stop telling me what I'm trying to do
and answer the question.
>> Are we going to talk?
>> Not if you're not going to answer the
question.
>> So, who is the master in the parable?
Answer.
>> Am I talking about something else? Am I
talking about
>> Who is the master? Who is it
>> exactly? You were only saying that there
he's trying to say you're only saying
out of context. Let's look at all.
>> Let's do this one last time.
>> He's talking about cognitive.
>> Who is the master?
>> The master is THE FATHER IN THE GOT IT.
SO THE FATHER'S GOING TO RETURN. SO THE
RETURN of the father. So the father's
going. So the father make the father the
son of man.
>> Right. So the father is the son of man
who's going away and then coming back.
>> The father is the one that has knows
what he's going to. So the father's
going away.
>> You say the father.
>> SO IS THE FATHER GOING? You said the
father.
>> Yes. Is the father going away?
>> So in the example,
>> is the father going away?
>> In Matthew 24:36,
>> Who knows? Who knows?
>> Even Jesus knows. Is the father going
away? Does not know.
>> Is the father going away?
>> Does the father know? Yes or no?
>> I I I'll answer this a second time. I'll
answer. I'll answer it a second time.
Yes. The father knows. So I answered
you. Now here's my question. The master
knows.
>> Does the father leave? And is the father
coming back?
>> Where is the father leaving to? Bro,
that is not this is
>> but you said you said it's the you said
the master who's leaving and coming back
is the father
>> because I'm saying the point of that
analogy is about cognitive knowledge. So
the cognitive knowledge that belongs to
the father. So hold on. No. No. We're
going to stay right here. You he going
to STAY IN HIS POT.
>> GOT TO TAKE it in politics, bro.
>> This is what's happening.
>> You're getting big right now.
>> This is what's happening. Let's This is
the This is steaming right here, boy.
This is This is in person. This is You
said
You said You said that the master is the
father. And now you're backtracking. So,
are you standing on it that the master
who's going away and coming back to his
house is the father?
>> I'm standing on the one who knows, just
like in Matthew, is the one who the
master is is the father.
>> The master Yes. is the one that knows.
>> So, the master that's leaving is is the
father.
>> It it doesn't mean he's going to leave,
bro. Just like the Noah flooded doesn't
mean that flooded.
>> I got you. I got you. So, so guess what?
So, the So, the master So, the master
who leaves So, the master who leaves Oh,
now he's coping now. Now, now he
attacking I know all of yall, bro. Y'all
thought y'all thought you GOING TO TALK
TO LOOK AT THE
>> Y thought you were going to talk to some
random bro.
>> You are random. You don't can't answer
the the question.
>> No, you can't. You put yourself in a
blunder.
>> Jesus gave you four examples.
>> Now the father's leaving and coming back
>> and you know nothing about their
>> So the father's leaving and coming. Say
it.
>> Why does Jesus not say about declaring?
>> Can you can you say that the father's
leaving and coming back?
>> Jesus give one example about Can you say
that the father's leaving and coming
back? Question.
>> Can you say that the father's leaving
and coming back? Say it. Did Jesus give
me?
>> No. Stop skipping and focus, my brother.
Stop skipping and focus. Stop focusing.
You're just trying to stop skipping and
focus about something that Well, no, you
do believe in this. You just said it's
the father that's leaving and coming
back. So, answer the question.
>> The father I didn't say that. I said the
father is the one that has knowledge.
It's like the master point of the Let's
do this one last time.
>> Don't try to be deceptive. You didn't
say the father's master.
>> You said the father's the master comes
back.
>> Not in the sense that he's the one that
the master. Not in the sense.
>> Why don't you want to talk about the
flood? He said, "Why did you want to
talk about the master?"
>> Do you realize any sincere Christian who
opens their Bible will know that you're
wrong?
>> Yeah. Every sincere Christian is going
to Every sincere Christian is going to
watch this dude is going to watch this
and they're going to see, man, this this
Muslim was nervous. He couldn't answer
honestly. He he never No, this the whole
thing is going to be Look, I I hope you
watch it. God lo, you know the channel.
You watch all the time. I hope you watch
it cuz your bakery is going to be on on
on display for thousands of years. One
question. How does he not give you
answer? You can't answer. He only gives
examples about
>> You're the only one who can't answer it.
>> Okay. So, I I got you.
>> I got I got you. And so, let's deal with
this for a second. When he's dealing
with I'm I'm talking to you. Wait. Stay
on the side. Unless you're going to jump
in. You jumping in. You jumping in the
pot.
>> All right. So, stay on the side. If
you're not jumping in the pot, you're in
the I agree with you. I agree with you
earlier. Did Did I not say earlier that
yes, Jesus is giving giving examples of
cognitive knowledge here? Did I say that
earlier?
>> Thank you. Wait, pause, pause, pause.
Now, did I qualify on who he's giving
the example of who has the co who
doesn't have the cognitive knowledge?
>> I'm taking one on conversation.
>> Okay. So, when I said when we mentioned
all of them cuz you're lying now. We
mentioned all of them. Each time he said
in these ways, you don't know. He
emphasized they don't know. Correct.
>> Correct.
>> No, he emphasized all of them talking
knowledge.
>> Regarding who?
>> Like not all of them was just one person
like the plug. He said to be my my
brother my brother here's my question my
conclusion I want you in in in the
parable when he finished it off and said
so just like did he say so in the same
way you don't know when the son of man
is coming or did he say in the same way
we don't know when the son of man is
no
they don't he said he can pull it up go
back to Matthew said they were getting
married they were still doing their
stuff so it was multiple people he
didn't say just one person I got you go
back to Matthew I got you.
>> Yeah, I know. We'll get back.
>> It's embarrassing. You can't tell where
it really is embarassing. I don't have
to give you an example of everything.
You're
>> trying to make Jesus say what he didn't
say.
>> No, you're trying. You're running from
everything
>> in your church father.
>> Can you get the verse out?
>> Matthew 24. Oh, yeah. So, Augustine
doesn't say he doesn't know.
>> Augustine says declare it.
>> What about even?
Let me give you said that Jesus gave it
to the father to be the only one who
knows by decision by giving him the
authority to declare it. So that's all.
So stay here. You know you don't want to
talk about the church father. Pull up
Matthew 24 and let's deal with what
you're talking about. Focus. Focus.
You're like a you're LIKE A SQUIRREL.
SQUIRREL. SQUIRREL. SQUIRREL.
>> We use the church.
>> Pull up Matthew 24. Pull up Matthew 24.
>> Yeah, I know. It's what I thought.
>> I'm right here. Don't worry about it. So
24.
Who does he say doesn't know after he
gives the examples?
>> So in the flood he said
>> that they took them away and they did
not know. He says they were eating and
drinking, marrying and giving in
marriage until the day that Noah entered
the ark and did not know until the flood
came and took them all away.
>> Keep going.
>> So also will be the coming of the son of
man.
>> Keep going.
>> You want to talk about the serpent one?
>> I already I already told you the talking
about
>> Keep going. Please,
>> bro. You're not just going to say stuff.
I'm trying to say I already conceded the
point that with the servant and master
one he says just like the servant
doesn't know just like you don't know
just like that the hour is going to come
>> well so so who's the they when he says
they didn't know when the when the flood
was coming who's the day
>> includes the angels in the heaven nor
the son
>> where does where does he where does he
include that
>> literally we're bringing it up it says
no
>> he doesn't say anything about them there
all he's talking about is the flood dude
>> no he's talking about the flood he's
talking about the other example
>> so in the flood who's the what he says
in in the flood. Who's the they that
he's talking about?
>> The people who were getting married that
didn't know their
>> Thank you. So, he's not even mentioning
the angels or anybody else. He's talking
about specifically the people when the
flood. Let me finish.
>> What is he trying to say?
>> Notice how you're not letting me finish.
So, he's talking about the people who
specifically in the in the time of the
flood. Now, keep reading. Read the next
one.
>> I know you guys hate context, but it's
all good. We just
>> You're the one that only wanted to focus
on what you still can't give me. Keep
going. Right. All of them about context.
>> Oh, I gave you an example. Keep going.
Um, where was I? Then two men will be in
the field. One will be taken and the
other left. Two women will be grinding
at the mill. One will be taken and the
other left. Watch therefore for you do
not know.
>> Wait, wait. Say that. Watch therefore.
So who?
>> For you do not know.
>> For you don't know. Huh? This had
nothing to do with the master. Doesn't
Hold on. Does it? Hold on. Does this
have anything to do with the master?
>> Did he mention the master?
>> No, HE'S TALKING ABOUT JUST
>> OH, SO IT'S NOT JUST WITH THE MASTER. He
says in all these parables and then so
he says so he listed so watch this he
lists the Thank you and you're turning
red. So he he lists the parables he
lists the parables and says watch
therefore for you don't know the time
and the coming of the son of man. So
talking about their cognitive knowledge
right?
>> He's talking about the ones that do not
know which includes heaven. Does he does
he include himself? Does he include
himself? Okay. and show me where he says
and so just like this we don't know
where does he include himself
>> Jesus said nor the son only the father
>> so what could be more clear
notice notice how bad you are at this
notice how bad notice how bad you are at
this
>> does Jesus say we don't know you got
>> okay here's the panic again I got you
all
>> you still haven't answered my question
brother no you did not you did not
answer my question it's my turn now give
example of declar It's my It's my turn.
We We showed you to be so incredibly
dishonest. It's our turn now.
>> Bro, you're the one being
>> Okay, cool. Can you get a Quran?
>> Get a crown, please.
>> I'm going to show you that Allah doesn't
know.
>> One is whether it's original.
>> No, no, no. Hold on. We can We can talk
about the Quran, bro.
>> Yeah, we're going to talk about the
Quran now.
>> This point.
>> No, you're done. You show that. You're
dishonest. You're the one that came.
>> We're going in circles. You're
dishonest.
>> Okay. Well, let's agree to disagree
here. Yeah.
>> So So So you lost.
>> No, you lost. How about this? We let the
audience decide. You can't give me one.
>> Let's let the audience decide.
>> You can't give me one example.
>> I I already gave it to you. I destroyed
you on this.
>> You know what, Avery? Can you open the
cross?
>> Jesus is not saying that.
>> Okay. Sure. All right. So, if Jesus says
he doesn't know, that means he's not
God, right? It can't be declarative. It
has to be cognitive. I got you. Go to
chapter uh go to chapter 19, please.
>> Please and thank you.
>> Are you going to talk about what's it
called?
>> You don't even know where I'm going.
>> If we bring this up, you're about to get
No,
>> bring up. You're going to talk about how
some people when Allah says they're
going to let them do their actions so he
knows what they will do. But this
knowledge is not about ACTION
OUT.
>> OKAY. So go read so go read about it. Go
read about it. Read the verse. This
>> is the easiest thing to respond to.
>> I hope so. Just Just like that. Just
like it was easy when I responded to
you.
>> This is sad.
>> Go to chapter 19.
>> You're going to start at verse 68.
>> All right. Right here.
So by your Lord we will surely gather
them in the devils. Then we will bring
them to be present around hell upon
their knees. Then we will surely extract
from every sect those of them who are
worst against the most merciful in
insolence. Then surely it is we who are
most knowing of those most worthy of
merit. Wait hold on.
>> What do you mean it's not
Allah is most do you read Arabic?
>> Yeah I read Arabic.
>> Okay good. So can you do you have an
Arabic Quran? That's a terrible
translation. This is Sah International.
I
>> I agree. And it makes mistakes a lot. So
it does. I'm going to show you what
Allah doesn't know. The verse he Subhan
Allah. Do you have
He is the most knowing.
>> Do you do you have Do you do you read
Arabic or not?
>> Yes, I read Arabic.
>> Can you pull up the Arabic?
>> Translate that.
>> That that translation is good.
>> No, translate what you just said.
>> Which are you going to pick your choose
your translation?
>> No, we're going with the Arabic. So
you're Since you speak Arabic, we're
going to go with word for word what the
Arabic says.
>> I got you. I'm going to pull up I have
the air on my phone here. Good.
>> I'mma pull it up too just so we can
parse out word for word what each one is
saying.
>> Oh, it is. It really is.
>> Look at the verse. Most knowing the most
knowing
when
>> when I'm not talking about English
translation when is he the most knowing?
So then we are with then we know right
now it doesn't even say most knowing is
most knowing there
>> read the Arabic does it say most knowing
in the Arabic one question
>> yes
>> it says most knowing
>> means
>> knowing right to know
>> no is know is no means like you're more
knowing
>> no it doesn't brother
>> I speak Arabic watch this
is that I know more than is that
>> this is just yeah this is the think of
>> Quran can you uh can you go to the
website go to the website cuz you can
highlight the words
>> to get his point across.
>> No, notice I'm the I'm the Christian
appealing to the Arabic. The Muslim
wants to appeal to the English.
>> You know, you know the reason why you're
losing is not because I'm smarter than
you. You're actually probably smarter
than you. It's because Islam speaks for
itself and it's a truth.
>> You know inside your heart that Islam is
the truth. You know inside your heart.
>> Honestly, you almost made me say just
now the historical narrative of Jesus.
>> Can you stop preaching to me? I'm
telling you the truth, bro. I believe
you believe that. You do this and you do
that and you do that. You know
>> that's the verse religion. Okay. Nice.
Says the one who circles the cabba. Says
the one who circles the cabba says the
one who touches the cabba and believes
it and forgives your sins. That's pagan
that you got from the pagan touching. We
can talk we can talk about we can talk
about that next. We can talk about that
next. Yeah. Yeah. We're going to show
you that you have you have misreading
comprehension. That you have a reading
comprehension. Brother, pull up the
verse. Why you running?
>> Pull up the verse. It's like this dude
is like a A SQUIRREL. SQUIRREL SQUIRREL.
>> CUZ YOU DON'T WANT ME to respond.
>> Focus.
>> Cuz you don't want me to respond.
>> Focus. Look,
>> bring up the verse.
>> Does is it quran.com?
>> Yeah, that's what I thought.
>> Thank you.
>> Focus of anyone's interest.
>> Yeah, it's in Isaiah. We all We all know
what you guys butcher.
>> It doesn't even say he kisses it.
>> See, you guys have terrible reading.
>> Oh, nice.
>> Quran.com
chapter 19. any anything to not read the
Quran y'all what they said
>> but your Bible but it's pagan and
>> worshiping a human is pagan
>> yeah so yeah so you shouldn't be
worshiping Allah
>> Jews and Muslims
>> then you shouldn't worship Allah
>> why why why do you worship a human
>> why do you
>> why do okay if if this is a good
>> focus you're putting your phone in your
pocket
>> this is a good argument from science
>> okay fine can you bring the verse
>> why do you
>> focus we can talk about that
>> you say focus but then you say STUFF SO
I'M
>> YOU'RE THE ONE WHO SAID DIDN'T HE SAY
YOU read the verse worship. Bring the
verse.
>> Okay.
>> He wants to say something, but he
doesn't want to respond.
>> Aren't you the one who just said
Christianity is pagan? So then I respond
to that and then you want to segue
somewhere else. Dude, focus. Then I
responded back.
>> No. So don't say stuff that's going to
get a response and then you try to focus
on that, you're getting distracted.
>> Okay. Quran 19. Which which verse?
>> What was the verse it was? Was it uh 70
or 71? I think it's 71.
>> Go to 71, I think.
If there's none of you 70
>> 70
>> surely there's we who are most of those
who are worthy of
>> so then
surely we
>> know best then we know best why so why
doesn't Allah know best before that
>> Allah knows best at all times just
because there's a I can give you
examples here let me show you just
because you have that preposition does
not mean that Allah did not know before.
>> So why does it say then that Allah knows
best? This shows that there's ever yes I
have. And the word and the word thuma
means then. Let me finish by
finish. Oh my goodness.
>> Oh my gosh. Is is is Allah giving a
sequence of events in this context to
get big.
>> Oh okay. You say is Allah giving a
sequence of events. Yes or no? In this
verse
>> Allah is talking about on the day of
judgment he is going to know. But does
it mean
>> oh he's going to know. So on the day of
judgment, he's going to know. So before
he doesn't know, but on the day of
judgment, he's going to know. No, that's
what THAT'S WHAT YOU JUST SAID. You just
said on judgment day, he's going to
know. So Allah is not God, brother.
>> You want me to give you an example?
>> No. Give me an example in this context.
Show me in this context.
>> You don't know the Arabic language.
>> So wait, wait. Trying to say the Arabic
is trying to say something that's not
saying.
>> So wait, so notice this. I got you. I
hear what you're saying.
>> Any Muslim scholar?
>> I just heard you.
>> Give me any.
Ah very good. So notice what just
happened here guys. So when I gave him
another context in which oiden or no can
be used to declare he said no no no show
me in this context that Jesus is giving
an example of declare. Wait hold on I'm
going let you talk. I'm going to let you
talk. And so then so so he demanded he
demanded that it be in this context that
the word oiden is shown to be declare
not cognitive knowledge. So, but when I
go to his verse and I show the verse
where Allah is giving a sequence of
events and then it says, "Then we know
best." So, it's not until judgment day
that Allah knows who's deserving to go
to hell and to heaven. He says, "Oh, but
in another context, I can show you that
the word then doesn't mean a sequence of
events." Do you see your hypocrisy here?
I knew you was going to do this.
>> I went in context when you looked at
Mark and Matthew and I actually went to
Mark and Matthew. You were the one that
didn't want to GO IN THE CONTEXT. NO,
>> THIS DIDN'T WANT TO GO into context. You
want to be guess what? Guess what?
>> So just like so just like you said just
like you said in Mark 13 and Matthew 24
that you stayed in context. So show me
in context of chapter 19 68 on that is
that that is then brother. Notice what
you're doing again. No you answer notice
you're dodging again.
>> Stop dodging. Show me in the context
that then is not a sequence of events in
chapter 19. So you want to limit me to
one verse in the whole Quran.
>> No, I I said context in chapter 19.
>> So So you don't So you don't want to
look at what the Arabic LANGUAGE
ACTUALLY MEANS?
>> OH, SO YOU DIDN'T WANT TO LOOK AT the
Greek.
>> No, I did. I told you oden. I I agree
that odin can mean declare, but not in
the Jesus.
>> Based based on what?
>> I just went to Bible hub and I see that
it has multiple has
>> one of them meaning.
>> Yes. One of them means knowledge.
Declare.
>> Thank you.
>> When you look at when you look at a
verse and it has multiple meanings, what
do you have to look at? Number one, you
look at what was the earliest
interpretations of that verse. Number
two, you should look at the context.
>> So you know what that verse means.
>> So what's the context of can mean
declare, right? It's one of them. It's
like nine out of 10 of them mean
something related to knowledge. But one
of them does mean declare or tell,
right?
>> But in the in the example that Jesus
gave, bro, your God that you worship, he
gave you four examples and you're still
like, "No, it means declare." He gave
you four examples by cognitive knowledge
and Mark and Matthew are different
chapters. So I looked into context of
your whole Bible. I gave you your whole
Bible as your paradigm. You don't want
to give me my whole Quran cuz you know
you're about to get faked trying to say
that Allah does not know.
>> Can I pause you here?
>> Okay. So I just listened to you. So
notice the difference between you and I,
my brother. The difference between you
and I is that when you you when you you
went to Matthew 24, you said you use
both context. I'm the one who told you
to also use Mark 13. I showed you that.
Yo, hold up. Let me let me let me
finish. I did not interrupt you, right?
>> Hold on. But I need to say this.
>> No, you don't, brother. I let you talk
>> when you when I talk about the
>> So, you're interrupting me again and
you're not even you're not even checking
yourself because you said something else
wrong.
>> No. No. You've been saying something
that's wrong.
>> Allow me to finish, brother.
>> I'm insisting that you allow me to
finish. I appreciate it. Self-control.
Okay. So, I'm the one who told you about
Mark 13.
>> You knew you used the examples in
Matthew 24. I showed you there's one
more that you're missing. and the and
the example in Mark 13 even you
acknowledge that that is the example
that you can actually use to to show
that Jesus does know because he's the
master who's coming back. So even that
you so in context of knowing the hour we
have in context of Jesus knowing his own
return. So now what I'm doing okay cuz I
agree that Matthew and Mark in the is
talking about the same thing. It's the
same context. So all those parables go
together. So what I'm quoting you to is
the context. In chapter 19, you have the
context of Allah about judgment day,
picking and choosing who's going to
hell. And he says, "On judgment day,
then we will know best who's most
deserving to go there." Now, you're
trying to argue that the then here is
not a sequence of events.
>> So I need you to demonstrate in the
context of chapter 19 of judgment day of
Allah knowing who's going to who's
deserving to go there. I need you to
show me in that context that it doesn't
mean what it says about Allah not
knowing until judgment day. Be
consistent.
>> Okay. You know what you just said right
now is literally one of the most sincere
tactics ever. You want to limit me to
one verse out of this.
>> I said context.
>> Hundreds of verses in the Quran. You
don't want to go to the Arabic language.
You don't want to grow the scholar.
>> We went to the Arabic language.
>> You want to go to one verse.
>> Arabic language. Show me in this verse.
Come on, bro. That is so insane.
>> I didn't say show me in the verse. I
said show me in the context. God sees
your heart. Why? Why? Why do you Why
would you say only show me in one verse
out of the hundreds and hundreds?
>> What's your name again, brother?
>> Why? Khaled. Cuz I'm talking to you,
man. Khal, right? I said it right. Okay.
Khaled.
>> I didn't say why. You're asking my name.
I said, "Why are you doing that?" Why?
Why did I ever say
>> Did I ask for you to show me in that
verse or did I ask for the context?
>> You asked only show me from this verse.
You said stay in this verse. You don't
want to look at the Arabic language.
>> So, this is where you want to look at.
So, I'm I'm going to say right here that
maybe you forgot what I said, maybe you
misheard me. I'm going to grant you
that. What I said was is show me in the
context of chapter 19 when all I was
talking about this very situation that
it's not that it's not that unjudgment
day. That's when he finds out. Show me
in that context. Meaning, you can use
the verses prior, you can use the verses
after. Okay? Because nothing in the
verse anyways it shows that Allah did
not have knowledge and then he started
to have knowledge that none nothing in
the verse shows that.
>> Can I give you my
>> Allah is talking about a sequence of the
events on the day of judgment. Not that
a sequence of events of his knowledge.
Oh wow. Now Allah knows who's going to
be in the but who get who where do you
get these arguments from?
>> So let's argue. So let's do this
together. Okay. Cuz it seems like you're
you're saying that nothing in the
context shows that it's a sequence of
events. Okay. So let's do this together.
Can you read verse 68? Let's go step by
step together and let's see what it say.
>> Three, four times. I showed you the car.
You said it's about
>> Let's do it slowly.
>> I showed you here. You said I don't like
that,
>> brother. We We already agreed that it
says then Allah knows best who's
deserving to go there. Let's read the
context together and let's see if Allah
is giving a sequence of events of this
happens, then this happens, then this
happens. Okay. So, can we can we start
there? Let's start at verse 68.
>> Let's do it. Let's do it together.
>> For the fifth time. All right.
>> Yes.
>> I got you. By the way, do the angels
declare the hour in revelation?
>> No,
>> they don't.
>> No.
>> Oh, really?
>> Nope.
>> What does this mean right here?
>> Why are you going to the Quran again?
>> Angels.
>> Why are you going to Why are you going
somewhere else again?
>> You want to talk about it after this
though?
>> No, we got we actually got our topic cuz
remember this is your topic about the
knowing the hour and the judge.
>> Got an hour of judgment day.
>> Oh, no it's not. So, this is our topic.
>> It says that on judgment day on judgment
day the the angels will declare the
hour.
>> No, it doesn't. Okay, brother. Can you
go to the Quran verse?
>> Wait, you said not. So notice when we're
trying to figure out what the Quran is
saying, I read it like he runs to the
Bible again.
>> I'll go to it again right now. I went
over it like five times so I don't
>> So let's do it one last time cuz you
didn't cuz you didn't get it the first
five. You didn't get it the first five.
Hopefully you have comprehension this
time.
>> No, don't worry about it. Don't worry.
>> Let's see who has comprehension.
>> Start at verse 68.
>> 68. So by your Lord, we will surely
gather them and the devils. Then we will
bring them to be present around hell
upon their
>> pause there. Pause there. Pause there.
So in that verse is Allah talking about
an event that's going to happen.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. It's a day of judgment.
>> Okay. And then does he give a sequence
like he's going to do this then this is
going to happen?
>> It's a sequence of events, not a
sequence of his knowledge.
>> Okay. Cool.
>> I'm I'm with you. It's a sequence of
events.
>> All saying on that day Allah will be
most knowing of who deserves. Doesn't
mean that on other days.
>> I got you. So slow down. So we agree
that Allah is giving a sequence of
events. This is going to happen. Then
this is going to happen. Next this is
going to happen. Then this is going to
happen. Right?
>> On the day of judgment.
>> Okay. Good. All right. So now
>> you just said it with your own words.
You event
Allah is going to
>> brother. I got you. Now verse 69. What
happens next?
>> 69. Allah says then we will surely
extract from every second those
of them who were worst against the most
merciful. So that happens after he
gathers them, right?
>> It's a sequence of events, correct?
>> Surely from insect of those. So yeah,
sequence of events.
>> All right. So now next verse, let's see
what happens next.
>> Then surely it is we who are most
knowing OF THOSE.
>> SO in the sequence of events, it's then
after they're gathered on judgment day,
then Allah will know who's deserving to
burn there. So it's a sequence of events
before before Allah didn't know. Yes.
Wait, wait. Let me finish and I'm going
to let you talk. I'm going to listen to
you.
>> Oh, you can say that.
>> So before Allah didn't know. Now he
knows cuz it's a sequence of events by
your own on that mission.
>> So show So if you can show me in the
context like I just showed you. I showed
you in the context. It's a sequence of
events. Show me in the context
otherwise. And then you got me
>> because there is nothing in the verse
that says Allah did not know.
>> Yes, it does. It says then
>> if we actually say that it makes no
sense.
>> Yes, it does. It means Allah's not God.
>> Okay. Okay. Look, look. Can you imagine?
Let's let Let me gr you your paradigm.
Let me get your paradigm. Look, look,
>> wait, wait. Can I can I
>> look at this? Wait one sec. Um,
>> I just want to steal them in your face.
Make sure you understand.
>> Uh, so Allah is saying, "By our Lord,
we're going to gather them. Then we're
going to bring them present around hell,
right? And they're going to be on their
knees. Then we're going to take from
every one of them who are the worst
against the most merciful." Right? If we
if we take this verse, then Allah will
now know. So you're saying Allah is
going to take them out and then Allah is
going to know. is going to put them on
their knees and then Allah is going to
be he's going to see which one of them
are worse at insulates. Then Allah is
going to now know on the damage. Oh, now
they know who's worse. You really think
that's a
>> that's what it says.
>> Laughing at it IS NOT AN ARGUMENT.
>> SO YOU'RE REALLY TRYING TO SAY ALLAH'S
GOING TO DO ALL of these things. Allah's
going to do one through.
>> What's your argument against it?
>> And then Allah did not know what he was
doing. Correct. He was just doing random
stuff.
>> Correct. Well, I was I was trying to say
like random. But he didn't know.
>> Oh, now I know. So this is
>> Oh, bro. You got B. Now watch, now watch
me do the same thing and I'll give it
over to you, David. So watch me do the
same thing. So watch this. I'm going to
do I'm going to do the same thing. Hold
on. I I listen to you, right? So now I'm
going to do the same thing you just did.
So you mean to tell me that Jesus
leading up to the to the saying that no
one knows the hour, he's given us all
the events that's going to happen in
detail. Who's going to be there? Where
people are going to be when uh uh uh the
events that what's going to happen,
people's emotional state when he comes
back, uh all the people that's going to
be scattered. He lists all these
details, detail after detail after
detail, how false prophets are going to
come, how this is going to happen, FALSE
CHRIST AND YADA YADA YADA STORM. HE EVEN
GIVES US THE WEATHER. But then he says
when he says no one knows, not the son,
the angels or the son of man only, the
father only. He then doesn't know his
own coming.
>> That's a BIG
That's a big
>> That doesn't make any sense.
>> You are using your premises. Let me
finish. No, no, no. I You got to let me
finish. I caught you though.
>> So this argument is dumb so low tier
like come on bro. You got to do that
your premise one of your premises as a
conclusion to support your premise.
That's a big fat circle fallacy. You are
putting that Jesus is the god. But we
are trying to prove that point. So
that's a fallacy. So that's why my
example your example is not analogist.
You tried but it was cute and it didn't
work out. Bro, that's a big fat circle
donut.
>> That's sad, bro. That's sad. uh uh
>> you came to to to sea state to get
baked. That's
>> yeah just uh to to kind of to kind of to
kind of bring it all together. Um
theatric
>> so his point so if if we if we convert
>> if we were to just go to that verse I
think you would I I think you would
agree. Let let me give the summary. If
you were to just go to that verse and
you knew nothing else about the Quran
and you just went to that verse, you
could interpret that as sequence and it
might sound like sequence and it's like,
you know, if we said make sense either
>> because like I said, why would
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, no, let me finish. Let
me finish. Let me try to represent.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm trying to
represent an accurate because because
what what I think what Avery is saying
is if if I said, you know, on such and
such day, Avery will be the best archer
in the world. That makes it sound like
he's not the best archer now. It's like
on such and such day that's going to be
the case. So just looking at if you
didn't know anything else you might
interpret it that way then he's going to
be this and then you have the immediate
context and he's saying there's nothing
in the immediate context that would rule
that out. So why wouldn't you go with
that? And I think what you're saying is,
yeah, but if you go with like the
greater context of the entire Quran,
that interpretation would make no sense,
right?
>> No, the Arabic language itself, the
meaning of the in the Arabic language,
if you look at if you cuz you said, "I
don't want English. I want Arabic."
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I'm saying I'm
saying you're saying
>> if you're Arabic and reading it, no, you
would not come to that conclusion.
>> If you just read that and you read
nothing else in the world and you had no
idea who Allah is.
>> No. Well,
>> and you read then he will be this.
>> Well, either even then, no. Why? Because
when you look at the sequence of events,
he's going to gather them on their
knees. He can do this.
>> You can do all that without being all
knowing or something like that. Like
like I can do all kinds of things.
>> Being all knowing. Why would he gather
them on their knees when he doesn't know
that they're the ones that are the
sinners? Obviously, he knows or they're
not.
>> This is when this is when he's going to
to decide or this is when he knows when
it's uh anyways when it's going to be.
>> No, I just I just want to I just want to
finish that point. So, yeah. And I think
what he's saying is then he'll know like
you know, books will be open and so on.
But I think if you say yeah if you look
at the context of the entire rest of the
Quran that interpretation wouldn't make
sense given what the rest rest of the
Quran says about Allah know Allah
knowing all these things and so that
interpretation would
>> because if you look at the Arabic like I
said if you know the Arabic and you see
this you can say yes mean
order but you look at the sequence of
you look at the context and you know
that also can mean something else then
you know that
>> so where in the context does can does
show that it means something else I I
dare you to find me any Islamic solution
or can you stop apping to authority
years ago or right now the text?
>> Yeah, I'm talking about the context of
the text. Can you show me in the context
that Thuma means something other than a
sequence of events?
>> Like I said, the con the context is that
how would he not know who's going to put
when the verse before says he's going to
gather them.
>> So notice once he gathers them then
he'll know who's who's deserving to
burn. So before so before he gathers
them he doesn't know.
>> No it's not about just gathering. It's
not about just gathering.
>> Okay.
>> It says he will present them uh bring
them to be present around hell upon
their knees.
>> Who?
>> The people who are who are doing the
wrong.
>> Okay.
>> Then we will surely extract from every
sect of those who are worse against the
most merciful and insolent.
>> Right. So there's going to be some he's
going to be separating he's going to be
separating the good and the bad. Right.
>> Yes. And he's going to know who are the
worst in rebellion.
>> Boom. He doesn't know who's the rest
until he detracts them.
>> That's verse 69. Then the one in context
that you're saying then it is we who are
most noted. So even the verse before
it's a sequence.
>> He's bro the se you just disprove
yourself. The sequence before says he's
going to take out the ones who are worse
in rebellion. You're trying to say after
that and now he knew.
>> That's when he knows when he extracts
them.
>> After he took them out.
>> Yes, that's what it says.
>> No, it says he took the ones that are
worse in rebellion.
>> And then what happens after that?
Wait, before he went there, does he know
which ones are Russ and rebellion?
>> No, not yet.
>> So, how does he take the ones that are
>> Look, this is this is what happens when
when he says this cuz look, it's state a
statement of fact, right? That he's
going to he's going to take look he's
going to take
>> uh right here
>> will surely gather them and the devils.
Then
>> then we will bring them to be present
around hell upon their knees. Sequence
of events.
>> Yeah.
>> Um 69. Then we will surely extract from
every sect those of them who were worst
against the most merciful and insulent.
>> I dare you to post the whole thing.
>> I dare you to post.
>> Oh, trust me. It's going up. No cuts.
>> So sick was cut. No cuts except except
maybe dead space. But it's supposed no
there was no dead space.
>> Okay. Then then don't worry about then
don't worry about cuts.
>> So you're not going to put cuts. All
right. Cuz you you take this out of
context. That's
>> Oh, you you say that. Okay.
>> But your video you don't show.
>> Notice notice you're getting distracted
as soon as we get to the part while it
doesn't
>> Well, we've been here for like 30
minutes. Okay. Don't act like that.
>> So then, so then then, so we already
agree all of this is a sequence. One
thing after another after another after
another. Then surely it is we who are
most knowing of who's deserving to burn
there. It's not until after he extracts
the e the the the sex, the worst of
them. That's when he knows who's deser
who's most deserving to burn in hell.
What I need you to do is is demonstrate
to me, not just because you just think,
oh, Allah has to know. demonstrate to me
in the context that it's not a sequence
of events
>> because how would he how because you
already agreed it is
>> because how would he how would he take
out the ones who are worse in rebellion
if he DOES NOT KNOW
>> BOOM AND HOW that's that's my thing so
my point is no my brother when he knows
that he's taking when when when he knows
who's deserving to burn there it's
because it's after he extracted the
worst amongst the sex so when they're
together
>> you're telling me there's a group of
people and he didn't know which ones are
bad but He was able to extract them
without not knowing.
>> No. No. That's not what he says. He
doesn't know. It says
>> No, the verse after it is that you're
saying then he knew, right?
>> Hold on. What you're trying to say, but
when he instructed them, he didn't know.
>> Can I can I answer you?
>> Yeah.
>> Because he's specific about what he
knows. Okay. He's not saying he doesn't
know who's bad. He already knew who was
bad. That's how he extracted the worst.
>> But it but before he extracted, he
didn't know who was most deserving to
burn in hell. So, it's not until he
pulls out the worst among them that
that's when he knows who's most
deserving to burn in hell. That's the
specific knowledge he doesn't have.
>> Bro, to be honest, you're going in
circles and I already answered it.
>> You ain't proved me wrong yet.
>> I proved you wrong.
>> Okay, we we can agree or disagree,
right?
>> You had to like, oh, I don't want to say
international even though it's one of
the most
>> Look at me appealing to the Arabic. How
dare I appeal to the Arabic?
>> You want to appeal to the Arabic? I
said, let's go in the Arabic. What
actually means?
>> YOU SAID STAY IN SAI INTERNATIONAL. I
SAID LET'S GO TO THE
>> I'm saying I'm saying that's the first
point.
>> This is going to be rewinded and your
words are going to be put up.
>> Second point. I told you let's go to the
Arabic. Let me show you in a context
where it can mean something else. Like
no just only this verse, bro.
>> So let's so let's so let's let's agree
to disagree on this point. Okay.
>> Can I bring up No, cuz look, brother,
you already brought up being God.
>> Hold on. Hold on.
>> It's our turn to be the top.
>> No, no, no. I brought up the hour.
>> Yes. So we were still talking about the
hour.
>> Not knowing. So now it's my turn.
>> We're still That was all the top of the
hour.
>> No, no, no, no. You were that was but
you had a point of contention in the
Quran
>> on the same topic.
>> No, it does not answer though.
>> That was that was to bring out a matter
of consistency.
>> Whether I'm a Hindu or I'm a Christian
or I'm a Jew or I'm a Muslim, it does
not matter whether Allah knows or not.
>> Yes, it does if you're a Muslim. What?
>> I'm What did I just say?
>> You just said it doesn't matter if I'm a
Muslim, a Hindu, a Christian, whatever.
It doesn't matter if Allah knows or not.
Yes, it does. You're a Muslim.
>> What did I just say? If I'm a Hindu or a
Jew, it doesn't matter. Right.
>> But you're not you're not tracking your
words. I'm literally you you just took
over.
>> Yes, it does matter cuz that would mean
that I'm
>> a Hindu. It doesn't matter.
>> It does matter cuz that would mean that
Allah is not a god.
>> It does not matter in the context of
proving whether Jesus is talking about
declarative.
>> Well, the Hindu I'm not talking to an
Hindu. I'm talking to you who brought up
the the the topic of Jesus knowing. But
let me finish.
>> You brought up the topic about Jesus not
being God because he doesn't know
something. So in the topic of God has to
know things, know all things, especially
on judgment day. This is was our topic.
So you brought up your objection. Did
Jesus not knowing the hour? On the same
topic, I brought up my objection. Allah
not knowing who deserves to go to hell.
All regarding uh God not being God if he
doesn't know something. That was your
topic you picked. Now it's our turn to
pick a topic. Look, that's not fair. You
know what? You know what?
>> Khaled, come on, bro.
>> Khaled. Sorry. Come on.
>> You brought a point. Sorry. I'm the one
that you let me Thank you. Thank you.
You let me go first. Yes. and we talked
about
then we stopped talking about that we
start talking about Allah whether Allah
knows whether Allah does not know
whether I'm Jew or Christian that is a
separate point of contention that does
not have anything to do with Jesus now
we're arguing
about hold on if I was if I was an
atheist and I came to Avery and I said
hey Avery I don't believe Jesus is God
because Matthew 24:36 and Mark 13:32 you
would not bring that up right that was a
separate point of contention so I
brought something up brought something
up. Now it's my turn again.
>> No,
>> he's pointing out on the same point.
>> If you don't agree to that, then we're
going to have to end the conversation.
>> Yeah, I I could talk I could talk to
someone else or you can talk to him.
>> No, just just just to clarify, it's it's
it's about it's about consistency. If
you're saying no, this word here's how
you have to interpret this. I I think I
think the perspective of a Christian
would be, okay, we have this passage and
if this passage in isolation could be
interpreted in this way or that way,
what happens when you factor everything
else in? one interpretation becomes far
better given everything else and and so
I think what he's he's comparing is if
you just go to surah n surah 19 that
passage and say uh well this sounds oh
sequence sequence sequence sequence and
then Allah will know that sounds in
isolation like Allah is going to finally
know something but if you look at
everything else that interpretation
wouldn't make sense and so you go with
an alternative just cuz it doesn't make
sense with the rest of the Quran and so
if you're basically if you're
interpreting what Jesus what Jesus meant
there you take every you take everything
into account that Jesus said and that
fits one interpretation way better than
being stop being a hypocrite
>> bro don't call me hypocrit and by the
way you rule out
>> hypocrite with your own Bible you didn't
want to go to the four pebbles I what
you're saying if what you're saying is
true that's correct but it is trueact
give me anything in the Bible
>> right I didn't say limit I didn't say
just limit to Mark I or sorry you did I
went to Mark when you told me go to
Mark. Yes or no,
>> brother? No. Yes or no? Then go to you.
You You said stick with you said stick
with the parables that Jesus gives in
Mark and and and uh in matter of fact,
you didn't even want to use the parable
in Mark. You you wanted us to know, you
did not you did not go to Revelation
when we were talking about it. You
stayed in Matthew 24 and I'm the one who
told you to go to Mark and but but then
you but then you abandoned that. You did
not want to talk about Mark 13 and you
wanted to stay about the parables in
Mark 24. I told you the example.
>> So you gave your topic. It's our turn to
pick our topic.
>> Bro, if you're gonna be dis anyone who's
watching this is going to know you
brought something up.
>> Sure, we'll go talk to We'll go talk to
somebody else.
>> If you're not being
>> But he he brought that up. That that was
not that was not that wasn't even that
was just if you're going to demand
certain ways of interpretation, what
happens when if you're going to
establish this rule, Jesus can't be God
because of this? Well, what would happen
if we applied the same standard? So,
that's that's him just saying, "Hey, are
you consistent on this issue?" That
wasn't like bringing up another debate.
>> Yeah, it was the same topic. We we have
another topic separate from what we were
just talking about. Not about knowing
God knowing and not being God. We have a
separate topic.
>> My topic is I want to talk about the
Trinity. I'm down to talk about the
Trinity, but let me pick a go back and
uh I want
>> But you're not being fair cuz it's my
turn to be offensive.
>> Brother, you you just gave it to us,
man. We just we just agreed. Brother to
brother, man.
>> No, we didn't.
>> I'm going to We're going to talk about
the trinity.
>> You brought a point, brother. We're
Listen, we're we're here. You know what
I'm saying? We're not going any
>> I'm in your face right now talking to
talk about the trinity.
>> No, I'm not.
>> He only wants to talk about Christian
topics.
>> I will talk. No,
>> he said that he will he said he said,
"Hey, we could talk about two topics.
You can pick one. I can pick one."
>> Y'all listening?
>> You listening, brother?
>> He said that we can bring up two topics,
right? Or I He could pick a topic. I can
pick a topic. I said, "Yeah, you can go
first." Said it should go back and
forth. I said you can go first. So he's
like, "Okay, yeah, I want to talk about
Jesus being God." Okay, sure. We talked
about that. I gave a counterargument
with his topic when I brought up Allah.
So now I want to pick up my topic. But
he's like, "No, no, no, no, no. You
already picked the topic." I didn't. I
gave a counterargument. No, he's not
trying to answer the question. He
doesn't want to talk about it. So then
he said, "I want to talk about the
Trinity." I'm still talking. And I'm
still talking. He He He said, "I want to
talk about the Trinity." I said, "Sure,
we could talk about the Trinity after I
get to pick my topic like we like like
we discussed. So my topic is going to be
the Islamic dilemma." He says, "No, I I
we we're I'm going to go first again."
Well, you just went first.
>> So, it's my turn to pick the topic like
we agreed before.
>> So, if you're going to be dishonest,
>> that looks like running.
>> Yeah. He's running from He's running
from defending his own.
>> Don't worry. Ain't nobody running.
>> So, you guys, y'all, as as Muslim
brothers, y'all need to be honest with
your boy, man.
>> Let me tell you my side.
>> Be honest with
>> Can I talk? Let me
>> Yeah. Go ahead and talk to them.
>> So, I talked to
>> I'm not about to be here debating about
debating.
>> We're going to debate about debating.
>> I talked about Jesus not knowing the
hour, right?
>> So, if he doesn't want to talk, what you
going to want to talk about? If you
don't want to let you Yeah. Yeah. Go
ahead. Listen to him. I'm going to go
I'm going go I'm going to go have a
productive conversation with somebody
who could be honest.
>> Why you leaving? If you don't want to
talk about the Islamic dilemma, if you
don't want to let me pick a topic like
you promised, then you have no honor and
we're not going to talk. It's simple.
I'm not going to I'm not going to debate
about cool. All right. Whatever helps
you sleep. And
>> whatever helps you sleep. I don't want
to talk to you.
>> I don't want to talk to you.
All right. You You got it. You got it.
Bye-bye sense again. Does a law make
sense?
>> Let me just
>> cuz you're saying a law is not like
anything in trying to run.
>> You hear that? Don't talk. Ladies and
gent
I'm trying to escape the hell.
>> As long as as long as you only agree to
talk about whatever I want to talk about
and nothing else.
>> Ah, that makes sense. Mah, that makes a
lot of sense.
>> Did he not talk about what he wanted to
talk about?
>> No, I didn't.
It's God. It's God.